hello how are you I'm good how are you
a Florida woman accused of shooting her
neighbor over a trespassing dispute
pleads not guilty in court all this is
newly released body camera video gives
us an inside look at a year-long feud
leading up to the shooting I don't know
what his problem is this guy in the next
building
there's no trespassing science kids have
been
dreaming yelling the body camera video
also shows officials speak with the
victim months before she's gunned down
it's funny because I'm the one that
never comes outside
58 year old Susan Lorenz is now charged
with manslaughter in the June 2nd
shooting death of ajika AJ Owens in
Ocala Florida officials say Lorenz shot
at Owens through a locked metal door
over a disagreement involving owens's
children who've been playing in an open
field near Lorenzo's apartment leading
up to owens's death Lorenz made more
than a dozen calls to the Marion County
Sheriff's Department about the so-called
disturbances claiming the children
bullied her and referred to her as Karen
I don't want to be intimidated by them
screaming and yelling at me telling me
calling me Karen I mean they're calling
me names really we're gonna you know
devolve to this simple bullying I don't
want to face this during this incident
Lorenz explains neighborhood children
play near her rental apartment she
accuses them of screaming and yelling
and disregarding a no trespass sign kids
keep running back and forth over here
when the kids are out front I don't you
know it's really noisy
events here they're screaming yelling I
don't get a break from the kids at all I
don't have children
I've asked them at least you know the
kids all live on that side of the street
for some reason they love to play over
here oh my guys probably because it's
open I understand that
I have migraines horrible migraines I
had a very bad car wreck I had my
nepheus I've had I need more back
surgery
you know there's other places they can
play they don't have to play here
they're screaming yelling at me tell
them the kids are not hurting anybody
the kids you know they're not damaging
anything it's probably damaging me
because the migraines are so bad most
days I could barely stand I'm on to
Pyramid I'm on a fewer sets of my
sumatriptan
I'm in pain I hear the children I'm not
trying to be a butt you know it's not
fun
okay well have you talked to your
landlord yes there's no trespassing sign
okay you know and they're saying that
this guy is giving them okay to be on
the property and now a word from our
sponsor introducing the next generation
of pepper spray meat pop a new maximum
strength self-defense product with a
patented modular design revolutionizing
the self-defense industry whether you're
carrying the unit on your keys snapping
the unit on your backpack your keychain
or carrying the unit in your pocket Palm
is the perfect everyday carry accessory
Palms patented flip top safety prevents
any accidental misfire and its maximum
strength formula provides you with the
necessary range and capacity to bring
peace of mind to you and your loved ones
quality safety performance Peace of Mind
learn more at palmpepperspray.com
on separate occasions Lorenz alleges her
landlord has instructed the children to
remain off the property but that the no
trespassing sign was stolen
um
businesses
what's going on this evening lots of
children screaming their full heads off
running around
um I had my truck apart from here so I
didn't have to listen to the screaming
and yelling as soon as I moved to check
the kids are coming up I like guys so
they know they're not supposed to be
over here
but sheriff's deputies hear conflicting
information when speaking to neighbors
you don't even come outside and play
football with the kids or playing so I
figure well the cops are there is
probably she she keeps calling every
time I mean it's just almost stupidity
literally it's just going around
some signs over here I mean we all live
here kids play over there it's an open
field where
um
she keeps mess around with the kids and
the kids sometimes they go like they
start cursing her and I'm like you know
what no don't do that you got to respect
her Jesus
I mean but she's she's not all there
during one of these calls Lorenz asks
sheriff's deputies to trespass children
she alleges are near her rental property
but officials explain that won't quite
work you don't have sole control over
the parking lot
yeah but those children don't look here
I mean they literally live across the
street on the other side they don't I
understand what you're telling me and I
get it but you don't have sole power to
say hey they can't be in this parking
lot
but he's asked them to leave I mean you
can call Charles I mean I'm just telling
you why
it's trespassing it's the first times
civil these days it's not it doesn't
become criminal until they're born
okay but he's already told him no
trespassing
who's he Eric and he's just trespassing
right now during this conversation a
neighbor approaches officials while
they're speaking with Lorenz she then
accuses him of trespassing he's just
trespassing right now
he's trespassing right now he's
trespassing
he came over to come ask us a question
what do you need us to do what do you
want us to do tell the girls not to cut
they can't come around and put them on
the phone I mean literally they cannot
come on
I mean I can talk to him if I can figure
out who they are but
I mean he's good because he's screaming
all the time too
okay it just needs to get
off when officials speak with the
neighbor he claims Lorenz may not be all
there mid-conversation Lorenz interrupts
them this is just an open field you know
it belongs to both property you know
what I'm saying so the kids want to play
there whatever and that's that's what I
keep telling me hey as long as you don't
get in heard the word you don't start
throwing rocks don't be cursing her it's
okay she could cut the cups whenever she
wants but
and and I was trying to reason with her
one day because we were all playing here
you know the kids everything jumping all
right let's go and she's like hey you
know what one day you guys are gonna die
and I'm like and that's when I like whoa
sure
it's a dog we can't stop the dog from
barking yeah but it's too much feedback
can you please let me know
all right well you have a good one
apparently we can't stand here and have
a conversation that's what I'm saying
right
multiple times First Responders speak
with children who say Lorenz calls them
inappropriate names were you the guys
that this lady was mad about yes and I
just want to say that every time like
even if we're not hold on hold on let's
bring it down okay I'm sorry you're okay
every time even if we're not on our
property and we're just like like being
loud and playing basketball over there
because there's a basketball I got you
like she she just calls us names okay
yeah like literally
um like literally all the kids because
that's an open spot right there yeah all
that is not
right here this guy has said numerous
times y'all come over here and play
because they all like to play football
okay so he's okay with it and that's
where they mainly are they're more on
his side what kind of names is she
calling you guys
retards the b word the b word the p word
everyone in the book like when somewhere
well the kids were playing right there
and it was just Dad outside and then she
came here she came out yelling and she
was talking about a little girl getting
raped and stuff like she's crazy like
she'll come out
weird I like I have said stuff to her
before because I one time I just had
happened to come outside and she was
calling them retards and I'm like hey
like relax these are kids here she
always calls her confidence
she tells us the F off and stuff and she
calls us
so she lived right across the street
though no she lives right there she's
like right here we played right here
yellow
she had um she actually oh yeah because
she every time I go I walk past she
thinks we're trying to steal her truck
or buy her truck
we're 11. okay
do you even know how to drive no
officials also speak with the parents of
children in the area who say their kids
often play in an open lot outside of
Lorenzo's
rentals
15 kids out here
yeah
it gets louder
yeah I try not to get on get on them
like that you know we all all the
parents are cool
on one occasion officials even speak
with Owens after Lorenz accuses her
children of bringing a dog near her
property
okay so what's going on okay okay young
ladies who just keep coming by and think
it's hysterical while I'm working to
bring their animals and
sorry
scream while I'm on the phone another
dollar let's just take the dog out the
other day she tells the kid tells my son
I'm gonna have you arrested and we're
going to jail he's eight so he's
terrified he won't even walk the dog
anymore let her know all that okay so
she's terrified I won't even he won't
even walk the dog anymore Owens explains
her confrontation with Lorenz that
happened nearly a year and a half before
the deadly shooting this is Joy Aaron
can't tell them they can't walk
on this side so
[Music]
she comes outside to go to the car or
something she sees him oh I told you I'm
gonna have you arrested and I'm like
happy the rest of the day she has her
phone out like she's taking this picture
with her now he's trying to run back
across the street so I said I'm sorry
what are you saying to him
and so I go over there
Lorenz appeared in court on Tuesday
where she pleaded not guilty to the
manslaughter charge right now she's
being held on more than 150 thousand
dollars Bond officials say she's likely
due back in court in September reporting
for long crime Network I'm Sierra
Gillespie